hello everyone and welcome back to
another great matchup from the fide
World Cup 2023 uh sorry about this let
me just rewind that it is the argument
versus pragnananda and Arjun defeated
pregnant with the black pieces yesterday
so now it probably wants the Air Force
tie breaks he's gonna have to do the
same it's not gonna be easy as Arjun
will make his well at least try to make
his life miserable even though they are
great friends and he will opt for the
same thing Magnus went for against uh
the album in Sicilian where white simply
doesn't lose so let's check it out Arjun
has the white pieces and he opens with e
for progos for C5 he wants a fighting
chance and of course Arjun wants to
minimize the thread as much as possible
so he plays Spawn to C3 the elephant
variation of the Sicilian and gookish
played the D5 against Magnus and he
didn't get all that much Prague tries
Knight to F6 here against Arjun uh we
have pawned the E5 Knights the D5 and
now Knight to F3 D4 is a bit more
popular but Knight to F3 the second most
power popular option Knight to C6 D4 we
have characters captures and pawn to D6
so they're all been played before very
standard stuff here Bishop C4 Knight to
B6 and now Bishop to B5 pinning the
Knight here so Bishop to D7 and now
Knight to C3 we have characters on E5
captures end upon the G6 we have castles
uh in the bishop to G7 putting pressure
on the pawn here so of course uh Arjun
defends it with Queen T2 and now the
queen and Knight nicely defend the E5
pawn and here we have castles
uh you could also consider some other
moves like maybe Queen to C7 maybe A6
but it's best to Castle first uh we have
H3 and now there are some games that
reach this possession where Queen to C7
and A6 were played but here we have
Bishop to E6 and it is now as of move 13
that we have a completely new game so
did frog get a playable position here
with black uh well uh well let's uh go
uh forward a few more moves and see uh
what happens Rook to D1 uh of course an
excellent um Square for The Rook attacks
the queen queen to C7 and the bishop to
F4 you have to defend your E5 Pawn uh
Rook 8 to d8 and now Rook 8 to C1 nicely
aligning The Rook with the queen Here
and Now Knight to D5 offering some
trades here and uh Arjun goes for a
knight captures on the E5 Bishop
captures and now Knight to D4 we have
Queen to B6 by Prague and here Arjun
devises a devious plan where he will
sacrifice a pawn but he will get um
incredible counter play and he well will
be the one seemingly playing for the win
so he plays Knight captures on C6 and
okay B captures on C6 Prague wants to
keep as many pieces on the board as
possible Bishop to C4 with Bishop
captures and C for Queen captures and
now Rook capture Sun D1 with check Rook
characters and Prague wins a pawn with
Queen captures on B2 so why did Arjun do
this uh well the trick is Ponte E6 and
now he will mess a prog spawn structure
and prog will have an isolated a pawn
and isolated C pawn and hopefully a
double isolated E Pawn and that's not uh
very good if you want to play for a win
so okay Prague goes back with Queen to
F6 it's the absolute best way to play uh
Bishop to E3 now preparing the capture
on A7 and create a past a pawn so okay
Prague says you do that I'm gonna
capture an E6 with my queen and offer a
queen trade so what does this mean it
means that frog will be up a pawn but in
an end game that you uh are not very
likely to win so Queen captures an E6 F
captures an E6 and now Bishop characters
and A7 and okay Prague also has a past C
Pawn but the past a pawn is a bit
stronger here so Rook to A8 and now
luckily for Arjun not luckily he of
course calculated it all the way at that
point where he first captured on C6 uh
Rook to D7 defends the bishop and goes
after the E7 pawn and now it's merely a
matter of advancing the past a pawn or
so he hopes uh at least we have King to
F7 defending the pawn and pawn to A4
with Bishop to E5 absolute best move by
and by progles we have to uh you know
decide what to play if Bishop to C5
lands uh King to F1 now it's time to
bring the king over to help out with the
attack and now Bishop to D6 with King to
E2 Now Pawn to E5 we have King to D3 and
King the E6 proc also activating his
King with Rook to B7 and now King to D5
nicely opposing the white king with Bond
F3 and pawn to C5 now so our Prague is
getting a lot of control play here but
still the past a pawn is looking very
very dangerous onto A5 we have Rook the
f8 and now Pawn to A6 with Rook back to
A8 and now we have King the C3 uh Pawn
to G5 by Prime controlling the F and the
H Pawn and now King back to D3 Arjun of
course very happy with the draw here he
says what what are you going to do okay
proc plays Pawn to H5 and here in order
to hold this uh Arjun needs to play King
to E3 but he doesn't he played King to
C3 and believe it or not now pregnant in
this position is completely winning and
well who would who would expect that
from an elephant Sicilian and it's a
really weird position like okay uh if
you if you see something like this uh
you you obviously prefer black because
black is the one up a pawn but
considering the situation in the match
where uh the black Rook is completely
out of the game and black needs to win
the game you just don't believe that
such a thing is possible I mean how do
you activate here but he allows it with
Queen to C3 and Prague finds it this
smooth 37 they are both very low on time
and need to reach time control but
Prague makes the absolute best move on
to E4 F captures with checked King
captures now King the C4 and now King
the F4 and now whatever you try is
insufficient let's say you capture on C5
well then Rook captures an A6 you no
longer have your star a pawn and if King
to B5 now you play Rook to A2 you simply
go after the pawns here Bishop captures
and e6e captures now Rook to F7 check
and okay you move the king king D4 and
the extra Pawn is very much winning here
on the other hand King the B5 which is
what the Arjun played uh Prague now
plays Ponte H4 we have rooked the D7 and
now King to G3 and here you have to make
a choice do you go for a race with King
to C6 and King to B7 or do you try
something else well we have to calculate
the race because if the race works then
we go for the race if King to C6 King
captures and G2 King the B7 attacks The
Rook we're gonna move the Rook Rook to a
fate now Bishop to B6 we have to block
the rook's defense of the A8 Square
Ponto G4 H captures Pawn to H3 Pawn to
A7 and now Pawn to H2 Bishop to d8 now
will uh ensure that the a pawn becomes a
queen but uh of course Prague will Queen
one move sooner A8 Queen and now both
players have a queen into the game but
King to G3 opens up a deadly Discovery
with King to A7 and now look at this
Rook to F3 no checks for white here uh
next move it's Rook to A3 and that's
pretty much it if you try Queen to B7
you still deliver Rook to A3 with check
and if King to B6 now just Rook to B3
check and that's uh that's all there is
you're gonna win the queen you don't
even have to win the queen you can even
Checkmate to the white king if you guys
want to see it Queen F1 check King day
seven you will play Queen to A1 with
check Queen to A6 and of course Bishop
to B8 with check the King has the move
you're gonna win the Queen Rook to A7
only move and queen captures on A7 will
be Checkmate so that is the race and
believe it or not these guys can
calculate that out all the way to the
very end and time control has been
reached this is already move 42 so both
of them have calculated this basically
in an instant we have Bishop to B6 and
now uh Pawn to C4 by prog and this is
again definitely the way to go uh
problem is if you try King characters on
G2 then Rook the A7 and then when you
once you move the Rook Rook to D7 and
now you will block the block the rook
and you are very very close to queening
and this will be enough for a draw but
prank finds the very strong C4 which
either creates a pass Pawn or King
captures and then you are much further
away from the action and then black has
all the Time in the World to actually do
something about this so here Bishop to
C7 was played now Bishop captures The
Rook captures and King captures and G2
Rook to C5 of course going after the G5
Pawn but uh probably not about to let
that happen Rook to G8 we have Pawn to a
seven and now King captures an H3
uh King the A6 with Pawn to G4 ink the
B7 and onto G3 and here uh it would be
it would be uh bad if you just play a
queen because then broke characters and
uh then after King captures G2 is
completely winning so he has to try
something else after G3 Rook the C8 was
played uh but even that is not enough
Rook captures on C8 King characters Now
Pawn to G2 A8 Queen and now G1 Queen
both players have a queen but Prague is
up three pawns so now it's merely a
matter of uh can Arjun perhaps find some
sort of a Perpetual maybe he can torture
Prague maybe win one of the pawns uh and
then maybe somehow get a draw well of
course he will try Queen to F3 with
check Queen to G3 uh Queen to each one
would check with King to G4 now Queen to
e for with check Queen to F4 blocking
now Queen to E2 with check King to H3
and now Queen captures on E7 okay so
Arjun wins one of the pawns but now it's
proc to move and he will try to escort
his Pawn to become another queen Pawn to
C3 with Queen to E1 and now Queen to F3
uh we have Queen to C1 and of course
King to H2 Queen to C2 with check with
King to G3 and now Queen back the uh C1
uh we have Queen to C6 with check King
to B8 Queen to uh D6 with check King to
C8 and now Queen to C5 with Chair King
the B7 Pawn to C2 and now a few more
checks will be given but of course both
of them know that that is now it Queen
to E1 check we have Queen to F2 and now
you can just give any check like if you
give this check Queen F3 blocks this and
you have to trade queens and then black
just gets a queen into the game so
Quinta sorry not E4 Queen the E5 check
was played uh we have King to H3 and now
Queen to E6 with check King H2 we have
Queen T5 with check now Queen to G3
Queen to C5 stopping promotion but now
just Ponte H3 and of course it seems
like you can capture a pawn for free
even though it comes with check you will
be countered with another check and now
you are forced to trade queens and then
the pawn just becomes another queen so
after H3 King the A6 was played but now
Queen to D3 with check King to A7 and of
course Queen to D2 guarding the queening
square preparing the queen few more
checks Queen E5 check into H1 Queen T4
check Queen to G2 now uh Queen to F4
guarding the queening square but now
just Queen to G1 check nicely connects
with the queening square and after King
to A6 Prague brought another queen into
the game and he was in this position on
move 75 that Arjun ergasi resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here so Prague does it uh he does
it uh the way that the googas couldn't
uh uh you know with uh with the still in
defense against the alapin uh really
really incredible stuff so you know
remember in the previous video where I
said that in the in the top tier game
black never wins that position uh well
it's not really true uh drug has done it
against his very good friend Arjun
edgesi they will settle it tomorrow they
will go into rapid tie breaks then if
they drew that into faster Rapids then
into the blitz then into faster Blitz
and then once I said that they will go
into Armageddon but that's not really
true for defeated World Cup in the
feeder World Cup if it's a draw after
all of that they go into sudden death so
there we have it very nicely done by
Prague bouncing back we'll see what
happens and one more game is still being
played from the from the semi-finals
we'll see when it ends I will probably
cover that as well the one between el
linear Dominguez Perez and Fabiana
corvana so once again really hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
and David Kimura for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day